una ola de calor con temperaturas de
hasta 37 grados celsius hace que muchos
alemanes se recurran a varios métodos
para mantenerse frescos por ejemplo un
chapuzón en las piscinas al aire libre
este es exactamente el lugar correcto
para estar las temperaturas están
tentando a las personas a la frescura el
agua y debes ponerte protector solar
beber mucha agua y meterte en la piscina
entrar en la frescura en berlín la
capital el vapor se aprecia a simple
vista y trabajar en estas condiciones no
es nada fácil
tengo que trabajar y no puede escapar
del calor
aquí hay ahora 36 grados y cuando
enciendo el horno automáticamente son 40
grados celsius un día entero está bien
pero si trabajo toda una semana tengo
que tomar descansos de lo contrario es
imposible seguir los bailes aunque
mientras algunos buscan refugio del
calor otros lo disfrutan de mercedes
perfecto para mí en este momento me
encanta cuando hace calor cuando hace
calor afuera cuando el sol brilla de
verdad el servicio meteorológico alemán
advirtió de una alta probabilidad de
incendios forestales debido al calor
extremo un escenario que se repite en
varios países del sur de europa como
portugal y grecia donde las altas
temperaturas también aumentan el riesgo
de complicaciones